we're going to begin this hour with the
head of one of the world's most popular
social media companies snap incorporated
the developer of snapchat remember
that's what was called back in the day
reports more than 600 million people use
the app every single month and about 330
million use it daily which is more
active by the way than users that
twitter has the company says it reaches
more than 75 percent of 13 to 34 year
olds in over 20 countries so if you've
got kids of that age in your house they
know about this and now snap is betting
its future on augmented reality what is
that
interactive technology that places
computer generated images over the real
world around you so when you look
through an ar lens for instance snap ceo
and co-founder evan spiegel is here for
an interview that that is cool for an
interview you'll see only on cbs
mornings good morning to you evan
spiegel we are so glad to have you in
the studio good morning thanks so much
for having me it was your first nerd
prom before we get into you what did you
think it was we had a ton of fun it was
wild to see like three thousand people
packed in there though i haven't seen
that in a while in a long time
so here's the big thing everybody's
talking about metaverse virtual reality
and you're saying yeah that may be good
but let me tell you about augmented
reality what do you mean by that well
our big bet is on the real world when we
started as a camera company more than 10
years ago we built an app that opens
into the camera opens into your
experience of what's happening around
you and we figured out that people had
fun expressing themselves with ar
effects overlaid on their video so we
took all the tools that we were using to
build those ar effects ourselves and we
made them available to the whole world
so that anyone could build augmented
reality lenses and share them with our
community and now there are hundreds of
thousands of developers who've built
over two and a half million lenses
that are used you know by 250 million
people every day on snapchat so what
could i do with it exactly i mean just
give me an example oh there's a wide
range of things you could try on a new
pair of shoes you could solve a math
problem by pointing your camera at it uh
sometimes you can even just overlay fun
effects on your face if you want to you
know express yourself with your friends
and when you were starting snapchat the
thing i like you don't do likes up or
down you know that's that's very
debilitating for a lot of people that
what was your what was your intention
when you started the company years ago
what were you trying to do well bobby
and i grew up with social media and what
we found was that people were only
sharing like that one percent of their
life that's really pretty really perfect
so there was a lot of pressure to get
attention you know this kind of big game
to get social attention to get comments
and likes online and so we wanted a
different way to express ourselves with
our friends and so when we built
snapchat there weren't public likes and
comments and actually the content in
your story for example disappears after
24 hours and that makes people feel more
comfortable expressing themselves
because every day is a new day well gail
mentioned the word debilitating and snap
is one of few social media companies
that are being sued by parents who have
lost their children due to suicide what
do you say to those who look at social
media might look at snap and say
this is unhealthy for teens you know
because they get lost in this vortex of
looking at things that might not be a
reflection of who they are
yeah well we purposely built snapchat to
support real friendships so people have
to both opt in to a conversation there
as we mentioned no public likes and
comments so there isn't that social
pressure to look pretty imperfect all
the time if you look at our content
platform we actually curate that content
platform so we decide what's allowed to
be distributed on snapchat and we work
with publishing partners and share
revenue with them to make sure that our
community has accurate and timely
information we also make available a lot
of mental health resources and the
reason why we're so focused on real
friendship is because there's a clear
relationship between friendship and
mental health in fact one of the best
predictors the number one predictor of
mental health and your ability to
withstand a depressive event is a real
friendship and is your ability to just
share how you're feeling and it doesn't
have to be a deep conversation just a
friend checking in and saying hey how
are you can make a huge difference so
we've actually built tools as well to
encourage friends to check in on each
other and see how they're doing because
that real friendship is so important to
mental health it's interesting we've
talked a regulation for a second you and
mark zuckerberg clearly have a
disagreement about whether uh virtual
reality in the metaverse is the future
or augmented reality uh zuckerberg has
been calling for some regulation of
social media do you agree with him that
things need to be done at the
congressional level and what would you
support
we definitely support thoughtful
regulation but i think the really
challenging thing in the technology
industry is that technology moves so
quickly that regulation is not a
substitute for moral responsibility i
think businesses need to take
responsibility for the products that
they offer especially when they reach so
many mil you know so many people we
reach over 600 million people and so we
need to be really thoughtful and
deliberate building our products and
making sure that they have a positive
impact in the world so i think
thoughtful regulation is important and
there's certainly a lot of progress
there europe's been moving uh you know
very quickly here and i think the united
states will follow but it's just not a
substitute for taking responsibility can
i just say you guys are always looking
for something new always looking for
something innovative and just last week
you released something called pixie that
i thought was cool because when you're
growing up and you're taking pictures
there's always somebody that's left out
of the picture you can't the so the
selfie stick will only get you so far so
this pixie thing follows you around
right there's tape of it there evan it
follows you around
it's a little drone
that takes pictures while you're walking
or whatever you're doing oh wow
you're like i haven't explained how it's
like your own little music video yeah
it's pretty cool we uh we actually uh
here here it is okay it fits in the palm
of your hand
he comes prepared it tells me you know
so go ahead it takes off and lands in
the palm of your hand you just select a
flight mode so it can follow you around
or orbit you and make videos and it is a
great way to get all your family in the
in the same shot and so we've had a ton
of fun playing with it uh with our kids
you know chasing it around the backyard
and uh you know i think the great thing
is that it's so lightweight and portable
you can just pull it out of your pocket
and fly my mind is blown right now i
know what's on your bucket list of stuff
you want to do oh my gosh just more time
with our kids i think you know they're
two three and 11 so that time just flies
we were talking during the commercial
break you know i have a household full
of users
of
um
um but but we were talking about certain
features that parents might not be aware
of um where you can keep a close eye on
your children not just with what they're
seeing what they could be talking about
but also where they are to the exact
location
talk about those features yeah we have a
tool called the snap map where people
can opt into sharing their location with
friends or parents we actually find
parents think it's really helpful for
carpool because you can see you know if
your if your friend's family has really
left the house to come pick up your
child
so so i think that's almost there yeah
just like you are
so so that's been a lot of fun and of
course not only can you see where your
friends are up to you can actually tap
in and see videos all around the world
so it's a really cool way to learn about
what's happening you know in the world
around you do you have any thoughts on
elon musk's possible purchase of twitter
well he's certainly a very passionate
super user of twitter so i'm sure he's
got a lot of great ideas did he offer to
buy snap before he went well
more daily active users he paid 44
billion so you're doing okay over there
evan hey you're not selling for anything
less than 100 billion that's basically
what you're saying tony heaven we
appreciate you thank you so much for
joining us and filled in some of these
tough questions as well